[APPLAUSE]
MARK LEYNER: Thanks for coming.
I think I'm going to read from
this book "Gone with the Mind."
"Gone with the Mind"
is about-- I really--
that's a questionable word, I
think, about, with my books.
It's a very
indeterminate fluid kind
of idea, what any of these
things are about in that sense.
But in this book,
there is a kind
of given, which is that I,
in sort of my present state--
I'm 60.
I am supposed to do a reading
at a mall in New Jersey.
And my mother drives me, which
says something about, I guess,
my feelings about where
my accomplishments at this
point in my life, that
my mother has to drive me
to my own reading in a mall.
But it gets worse actually.
The reading is in the
food court of a mall,
and no one comes,
absolutely nobody, zero.
I thought that might happen.
I've been waiting, in doing
readings for this book,
to do one where no
one came and that
would be-- I would
then have been sucked
into the vortex of my own book.
You ruined it.
Anyway, no one comes
to the reading.
There are two Panda Express
workers in the food court
who are sitting sort of
off in the periphery.
And I kind of pretend
they're there for the reading
and try to include them.
Like I'll say something
and say, right?
And they'll say, "We're
not at the fucking reading.
We're on break."
You know, they get
really incensed when
I try to include them.
So that's sort of the book.
My mother introduces me
for about 40, 50 pages,
talking mostly about
her pregnancy with me
and what it was like to be a
woman in the late 50s in Jersey
City, New Jersey
and being pregnant.
And then I come on and really
never get to the reading.
I just sort of do
what I'm doing now.
I just endlessly
contextualize the reading,
but never actually get to it.
And then there's a Q&A.
There are no questions really.
My mother disappears
and I panic.
And I run all over the mall
trying to find her, and find
her in the ladies room.
And she's in a stall.
And she says, come in.
I want to show you something.
I don't want to tell
you what happens.
It's just, spoiler alert.
So there's an
interesting character
in the book called
the Imaginary Intern.
And I was going to read you
a couple of little things
about The Imaginary Intern.
But I'm going to wait.
And if there's time,
let's see how we feel.
There's sort of two
little set pieces.
I don't want to
make this too long.
It's in the middle of the summer
and lunchtime in the summer.
So I don't want to
go on and on here.
So I'm going to read you a
piece about a job I once had.
And then I'm going to read you
a piece about my urologist.
I have a picture
of my urologist.
I'll show you.
It's a special treat for today.
I'll show you that.
I'll show you that when it's
time, when it's appropriate.
And if, when I'm
all done, you're
just dying to hear a little
bit about the Imaginary Intern,
we'll do it.
Let's see.
Let's see how we feel
when it comes to that.
"In the '80s, I had
a job as a waiter
at a place in Jersey City
called the Summit House.
And one of the first
tables I ever waited on
was a deuce in restaurant lingo,
a middle aged married couple
for whom Friday night dinner
at this particular spot
was a custom, a ritual
they'd really spruce up for.
He always in a carefully pressed
polo shirt, seersucker jacket,
and dark slacks, she in some
sort of floral print dress,
pretty earrings, a pretty
tortoise shell comb
in her hair, that sort of thing.
The husband pronounced
his Rs as Ws,
a speech defect called
R-labialization,
most famously portrayed,
of course, by Elmer Fudd.
So this exceedingly pleasant,
exceedingly soft spoken guy
would, each and
every Friday evening,
invariably order a "Wob
Woy," very "dwy," a "wum"
and Coke for my wife, the
"pwime" "wib" very "wawe,"
and the "bwoiled scwod."
'And would it be possible
for my wife to have
that with "wice"
instead of "fwench fwies,"'
he'd politely ask each and every
time.
I never questioned the
authenticity of the order.
Yes, it seemed
improbable that someone
who couldn't
pronounce the letter R
would never, just randomly in
the course of events, order
anything R-less, say a
gin and tonic or a scotch
or a steak or a veal chop
or spaghetti and meatballs
or a chicken pot pie.
But I just figured
he knew what he
liked, knew what his wife
liked, and that was that.
He seemed like a perfectly
decent sort of guy,
and I had absolutely no
reason to doubt his sincerity.
And there'd always be dessert,
the inevitable "bwead" putting
and "wed" velvet
cake, and at least
two "bwandies," all
of which added up
to a hefty check for two
people with a potentially
substantial tip.
So you want to be as
accommodating as possible.
One Friday night-- this must
have been after waiting on them
for two or three weeks
in a row, the husband
asked me some variation on
the question, assuming you
don't want to be a
professional waiter
all your life, what do
you really want to do?
And I said that I wanted
to be a writer someday.
And he said that he and
his wife loved to read.
And I asked who are
your favorite writers.
And he thought for a
moment and he said,
'I love Joseph "Conwad,"
"Waymond" Chandler,
and especially "Gwaham Gweene."'
Now at this point, I
remember I did look around,
feeling momentarily that I might
be being punked in some way,
in some sort of Candid
Camera stunt or something,
that someone had
put him up to this.
But again, I really
had no reason
to think-- in fact it seemed
a little crazy for me to think
that this seemingly
guileless person was
in on some sort
of elaborate prank
that was taking
weeks to develop.
And who'd want to do
this to me anyway?
I barely knew any of the other
waiters or staff at this place.
But still, no R-less writer?
No Melville, no
Poe, no Hemingway,
just 'Conwad' and
'Gweene.' I mean, come on.
What are the odds here?
I was just about to
head back to the kitchen
to pick up one of my
other table's orders
when the guy said,
I also love music.
I took a deep breath.
'Oh,' I said.
'What kinds of music?'
And again he thought
for a moment or two.
And then he said, I love
the "Wamones," "Woxy"
Music.' And especially, and
this he said in a much louder,
more declarative voice,
'especially Guns N' "Woses."'
And at this moment,
I was positive I
heard people sniggering,
that there were
little contingents
of my cohorts huddled
in corners of the
dining room barely able
to control their laughter.
And I felt this
radiant heat rising
from the back of my neck.
And I felt as if my face must
have been bright, bright red
with humiliation.
And although I never actually
saw anyone laughing at me,
I knew that they were.
Who they were and why they did
that to me, I'll never know.
And yes, it's possible that
a middle aged man from Jersey
City with R-labialization
could like
'Wob Woys,' 'pwime wib,'
'Gwaham Gweene,' and Guns
N' 'Woses.' But it's such a
remote possibility it has to be
pretty much inconceivable.
Someone or some people
were behind all of this.
And their identities
will also remain forever
in the nine enigma file.
And I also like to think that
this particular event, I guess
because I felt so
abjectly alone,
so on display at that
moment in that dining
room full of people,
in that particular food
court, that this event
not only instilled
in me a wariness
and a hypervigilance
and suspiciousness and maybe
even paranoia that have never
abated, but also a weird
masochistic love of precisely
this sort of public humiliation.
And I'm not saying
that's necessarily
a good thing or a bad thing.
I'm just saying that
that's probably why
we're all here this morning.
And again, I'm extremely
grateful for the opportunity."
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, this is an
issue of-- I don't
know if it's this year's last
year's, "Best of New York."
It includes all
sorts of categories.
Here's a little section,
best doctors in New York.
This is David
Samadi my urologist.
I just show this
to you so you can
visualize the person
I'm going to be
talking about-- dapper guy.
And when I started
seeing David, Dr. Samadi
and I guess he Googled me,
found out I was a writer,
and became interested in the
notion of perhaps the two of us
collaborating on
his autobiography.
It may seem odd.
So sometimes we would meet at
the bar at the Four Seasons
hotel, which is much
more pleasant then
the intimidating environment
of a doctor's office.
Anyway, this is a bit
about the two of us.
"Once Samadi and I
were having a drink
at the bar at the
Four Seasons hotel
up on 57th street
near his old office.
And he was saying
to me, 'You know,
once they're
diagnosed with cancer,
they forget about the
blueberries and come
to me,' referring
I think to men who,
when contemplating
cancer in the abstract,
are willing to consider all
sorts of alternative treatment
modalities, but when actually
diagnosed with the actual
disease in their actual bodies,
want the fucking cavalry called
in.
Samadi's a very interesting
guy with a very Dickensian
biography.
He was born and raised in
the Persian Jewish community
of Iran.
And then after the revolution,
when he was only 15 years old,
moved to London with his little
brother, just the two of them,
completely on their own.
When I met him, he
was the vice chair
of the Department of Neurology
and the chief of robotics
and minimally invasive
surgery at Mount Sinai.
And now he is at
Lenox Hill Hospital
where he's the chair of
urology and the chief
of robotic surgery.
In 2012, sometime--
I don't remember
the month-- I was
diagnosed with high grade,
capsule contained Gleason
7 prostate cancer.
And I pretty much
knew from the moment
I first sat down
in his exam room
and we discussed my
situation that I wanted
him to perform the surgery.
Of course I got
a second opinion.
I went down to Johns
Hopkins and consulted
with a very renowned
urologist down there.
This is an episode that
my mom and I have entitled
fingerbanged in Baltimore.
In addition to the
eminent neurologist,
there seemed to be
a veritable chorus
line of interns, half a dozen
eager young men lined up
snapping on their latex
gloves waiting to stick
their fingers up my ass.
It was like being in some sort
of sick Busby Berkeley routine
with a Giorgio
Moroder soundtrack.
All the urologist I've ever met
exude a certain morbid elan.
After all, their [FRENCH]
is the digital rectal exam.
I became so accustomed
to the procedure
that once I reflexively
dropped my pants and bent over
at the dentist's office.
The hygienist looked at me like,
dude, it's just a cleaning.
But with Samadi
there's a flamboyance,
a swaggering fighter
pilot sort of bravado
that I responded to very keenly.
He really does possess
this imperturbable aplomb
and a kind of-- I don't
know any other way
to describe it-- a kind
of star quality that
inspires absolute confidence.
We're there at the Four
Seasons, at the bar,
and he's explaining
the anatomy to me,
how the prostate is embedded
within various crucial nerves
that control urinary continence
and erectile function.
And he's joking with me
that God put the prostate
in such a difficult
place in order
to make it even
harder for Samadi
to challenge his virtuosity.
But he said that he,
Samadi, was like Tom Cruise
in that scene in
Mission Impossible"
where the guy's dangling
in midair by the two wires
and without triggering any
of the laser sensors, hacks
into the CIA computer.
In other words, Samadi
stealthily enters the body,
deftly delicately
removes the prostate
and gets out, without so much
as even grazing a single nerve,
leaving you in full
possession of your manhood
and your dignity.
And I was so inspired
by what he was saying,
by his zeal, his steely
self-possession, his sangfroid,
that-- and I'm not
being facetious here--
I suggested we just
go into the men's room
and that he remove my
prostate right then and there.
That's how charismatic he is.
That's the complete, absolute,
let's do this allegiance
he instills in his patients.
Granted I had several
cocktails in me.
I remember thinking to
myself at Mount Sinai,
just as they administered
the anesthesia, if you end up
incontinent and impotent,
don't be a baby, deal with it--
and then laughing.
That would actually
make me a baby.
I mean those are pretty much
the two key characteristics
of a baby.
And then waking up in
what felt like an instant,
an enormous pain, and with
a catheter stuck in my dick
and like five big
holes in my belly
like some innocent
bystander in a drive by.
But the good news was-- and
I wouldn't know this for sure
for a while-- but I am neither
incontinent nor impotent,
and all praise, all glory
goes to David Samadi.
I was extremely,
fanatically devoted
to doing my kegel
exercises, which
one does postsurgery to
ensure full restoration
of urinary continence.
I put my gym rat
instincts, honed
over the course of a
lifetime, to good use here.
I did those kegels
a dozen times a day,
counted them off on a set
of orange prayer beads
that I bought just
for that purpose.
I still do them, a
set in the morning
and a set before I
go to sleep at night.
And I now have-- and I say
this with a complete lack
of humility-- the
strongest urinary sphincter
muscles in the world.
I think they will long
outlive the rest of my body.
In fact, you know how people
say that cockroaches will
survive a nuclear armageddon?
I think cockroaches and
my urinary sphincter
will survive the
nuclear armageddon.
And I think that at some
point, the cockroaches
will ask my urinary
sphincter to be their leader.
I guess this is my own version
of Manson's Helter Skelter
scenario.
Because of what he did for me,
I've got David Samadi's back
for life.
I consider him my homeboy.
And I consider his
robot my homeboy too.
When old Yurok Indians
get sick, eels,
along with acorn
soup and seaweed,
are the food they crave.
When I return home
from the hospital,
I wanted Peeps and Peanut M&Ms,
cocktail weenies and marzipan.
But I was only
allowed clear liquids
at first and then
soft food, pabulum.
Is there a less virile look
to present to one's wife
than an open plaid robe, a
catheterized penis, and a urine
collection bag
taped to your thigh?
What can you do with
this, I mean fashion wise,
tape the bag at a
sort of rakish angle?
I would look in the
mirror myself and think,
this must be the most
abject, undignified,
de-eroticized version
of a man possible.
I should read you
the instructions
they gave me at the hospital.
There are like 23
pages of instructions.
It was like a fucking novel.
Take one cipro two
times a day, one
Colace every eight hours, 50
milligrams of Lopressor two
times a day, one oxycodone
every four hours,
plus applying antibiotic
and lidocaine to the entry
side of the catheter; rinsing
the urine collection bags;
repositioning the taping
of the catheter and the bag
to prevent blistering; what
to do if you experience
abdominal distension, bladder
spasms, bloody drainage,
ankle swelling, perineal
discomfort, scrotal swelling,
painful sneezing; what to
eat until you pass gas;
what to eat once
you have passed gas;
when to call to get the results
of the pathology report;
about whether there's additional
cancer in surrounding tissue;
when to call to schedule
the removal of the catheter.
Anyway, Mercedes--
Mercedes is my wife--
Mercedes would
bring me scrambled
eggs and toast or macaroni
and cheese or just pastina
with butter or whatever.
And she would have made exactly
the same thing for herself
so I wouldn't be envious
of what she was eating.
And I'd say, 'You don't
have to do this you know,
sit here with me and eat it.
It couldn't be all that
appetizing.' And she'd say,
I want to.'
And when we were
finished eating,
she would lie next to me,
my catheter trailing down
the side of the bed
into that bag that I
would lay on the floor.
And she'd hold my hand.
And I don't think I
ever felt more loved
than at that very moment.
It was just the most
wonderful thing.
Isn't it crazy that when I was
in this abject, humiliating
state, somehow that week was
a kind of honeymoon, really,
like a kind of honeymoon
in Paris or something?
It was.
And if I were to make a coat of
arms, an escutcheon, or perhaps
a new tarot card to represent
love, to represent caring,
it would feature a catheter,
a dish of scrambled eggs,
and clasp hands.
It was just the most
beautiful thing anyone
had ever done for me.
It was the most romantic
thing in the world
for Mercedes, this
sweet, sweet person,
to hold out her hand
to me like that.
It was just the most-- it
was just the happiest moment
of my life."
Thank you.
So what would you like?
I could read you about
the Imaginary Intern
or you could ask
me some questions.
I don't know if you do you
have questions about this.
I think I probably covered it--
[LAUGHING]
--comprehensively.
But if you don't--
no, I'm joking.
You may.
You may have.
What would you like?
What time is it?
How are we doing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 30.
MARK LEYNER: Oh, OK.
I'll do these
really quickly, just
to give you-- this is a very
interesting kind of phenomenon,
the Imaginary Intern.
There was a bathroom
in my house.
I live in Hoboken
across the river.
And when I would
sit on the toilet
and look down on the
floor, there was a tile,
and it was cracked.
And it was cracked in such a
way that it looked like a face
to me.
And the face became
more and more real to me
as years went by
and became someone
I called the Imaginary
Intern, and who
would just help me with things.
I mean, this may
sound crazy to you,
but there was
something quite real
about the Imaginary Intern.
I don't know, it may
be symptomatic of maybe
not growing up
with a real brother
or maybe I need
more friends or I'm
just this very isolated sort of
person, a very insular person.
But I really cherish
this . relationship.
And the Imaginary Intern
helped me a great, great deal
writing this book.
And then in the middle
of writing the book,
the Imaginary Intern vanished.
And it was very sad for me.
And that's sort
of a tragic thing.
And I talk about that in
the book a little bit.
So I'm just going to read
you four really little things
about the Imaginary
Intern, just for a sort
of clinical purposes.
This may be happening to a
friend of yours or something.
This may be useful to you.
Here I describe how the
Imaginary Intern came to be.
"I was sitting on the
toilet one morning,
gazing down at the tiles
on the bathroom floor, just
staring at the vein patterns.
And the craquelure on this
one particular tile and I
discerned a legible face.
I discerned the lineaments
of the Imaginary Intern
in the craquelure of a
tile on the bathroom floor.
That's exactly how the Imaginary
Intern was conjured up.
This is a textbook
delusion of reference,
specifically a pareidolia,
a psychological phenomenon
that involves seeing
meaningful patterns,
frequently faces, in
random information.
A common example of
which is something
like seeing the face of Jesus
in a Cool Ranch Doritos,
or something along those lines.
And the Imaginary
Intern initially
functioned mainly as a kind of
archivist or production manager
"Gone with the Mind," helping
me collate and categorize
autobiographical material.
But soon he became
more like a, I
don't know, more like
a coach or a trainer.
You know that term
in pharmacology,
mechanism of action?
It's the specific
biochemical interaction
that basically enables a
drug to do what it does.
When you're writing something,
its mechanism of action
is a very difficult
thing to identify.
It's a very subtle,
very elusive thing.
But it really is the
crucial fucking thing.
And when I felt like I had
lost that, that I suddenly just
didn't know what it
was, or when, you know,
I just felt kind of
discouraged or dispirited
about how it was all
going, the Imaginary Intern
would exhort me.
He'd pumped me up.
He'd be like, Denzel Washington
can land the plane upside down
stinking drunk and you can't
write an autobiography,
a book about your own life?
Are you fucking kidding me?'"
So that's just an example of
the kind of real exhortations
and assistance I would get
from the Imaginary Intern.
And I'll read a section
just to give you
a sense of our
relationship in terms
of it being a kind of
intimate relationship of two
close friends.
"The Imaginary Intern
and I used to love
this commercial for Dove
Dry Spray antiperspirant.
There'd be a series of women.
And each woman would raise one
arm in a gesture pretty closely
resembling the Roman salute,
spray on the antiperspirant,
stroke her underarm
with the index
and middle fingers
of her other hand,
and then snap her fingers to
demonstrate that the product
goes on instantly dry.
Both of us, the Imaginary
Intern and myself,
thought that it was
exceptionally beautiful.
And if he was watching
TV and it came on,
and I was doing something
somewhere else in the house,
he'd call out.
He'd call out, Mark.
One time he actually called
me Tweezers, like the kids
did at summer camp.
He was like, 'Tweezers,
the Dove commercial is on.'
And we started doing the
gesture for each other,
a quick swipe of the armpit
and then the finger snap.
It was a cute little
thing between us,
our little gang sign I guess.
But it's odd.
As time went on, it somehow
came to mean something
much more to us.
It came to represent-- and
this was a completely tacit
understanding, not something
we ever broached out loud.
The gesture, [SNAP],
came to represent,
to symbolize equanimity
in the face of death,
and perhaps-- and I
say this in hindsight--
perhaps even an
infatuation with death."
The reading that I do in
the book at the food court
is part of something
called-- apparently
they have a reading series in
the food court of this mail,
and it's called Nonfiction
at the Food Court,
or something like that.
That's the series
I was reading in.
It comes into play a bit.
"The Imaginary Intern really
did fervently believe, as do I,
in this whole idea
of staying secret,
of shunning the spotlight.
And a friend of
mine once suggested
that someone make a documentary
about the Imaginary Intern,
set up cameras all over the
house like in that movie
"Paranormal Activity."
And I told the Imaginary Intern
about it, and he freaked.
He hated the idea.
And I immediately regretted
having told him about it.
It was a huge mistake.
And sometimes I think that
that's actually why he left.
He just want it to be
completely off the radar,
left alone, completely
inconspicuous,
completely off camera.
I don't know if he'd been
abused in his life or what,
but he just wanted to
be able to relax and act
as loony and as
dorky as he wanted to
without having to worry about
what anyone else thought.
And I think the idea
of a documentary
just really shook him up.
It really spooked him.
And I think I mentioned
before that I've
tried to reconjure his face
from the configuration of cracks
in the tile floor
of other bathrooms.
In fact I was
sitting on the toilet
in the mens' room in the
Nordstrom at this mall
actually, and I
thought I discerned
his face in some
craquelure on the floor.
And I remember I was
concentrating so hard on it,
trying so hard to force a
jumble of disparate features
into a recognizable physiognomy
that I was actually straining,
you know, pressing in that way
that can cause hemorrhoids.
So I had to stop.
I've had that sudden frisson,
that jolt of, it's him,
many times.
And I'll squint and I'll
look from different angles,
and it's inevitably
a false alarm.
It's not him.
And it's a big, big
letdown, it really is.
It's a shitty feeling
But that's what
nonfiction is people, shitty
feelings and encounters
with death.
And that's why we're
here this morning."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I want to read you
one last little thing,
and then we'll see.
"I don't know if
you guys have ever
run into people who do
this cute sort of thing
when you're talking to
them, where if you say XYZ,
they'll say you're XYZ.
I knew this girl who used
to do it all the time.
Like I'd say something
like, 'There's a hegemonic
comparative in cross-training
sneakers.' And she'd say,
'You're a hegemonic imperative
in cross-training sneakers.' Or
we'd be out at a
restaurant, and I'd say,
'That pasta looks like a bowl
of infant foreskins.' And
she'd say, 'You're a bowl
of infant foreskins.'
So once the Imaginary
Intern said to me--
and I don't remember
what the context was--
but he said that memory, and
in a sense autobiography,
is like a rash that
blossoms and fades.
And I said to him, 'You're
like a rash that blossoms
and fades.' And then,
after he was gone,
I realized that he actually was
like a rash that had blossomed
and faded, an ache that
time will never assuage."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You're the greatest
audience I've ever had,
as I expected you to be.
I don't know what more to say.
Do you have any questions
about anything at all?
AUDIENCE: Why did you decide
to write an autobiography?
MARK LEYNER: Oh,
I think you have
to come up to the microphone.
Take your time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Hello.
Why did you decide to write an
autobiography at this point?
MARK LEYNER: Here's why.
When I'm writing a
book, I look at my work
in a way that may be different
from the majority of writers.
I get the sense that it is.
I'm not the sort
of writer or person
who thinks there are
things I need to get out,
there things that I
need to convey to people
or there's some sort of an inner
narrative that I'm storing up
and I need to convey
in some way or that I
have certain incredible
theories or sentiments that I
need to convey.
Books to me are always-- I think
I was very influenced by when
I was a teenager, or let's
say 14, 15, 16, by the way
painters thought
about their work
and painters would think about
doing a series of paintings
with certain kind of
technical problems
or certain aesthetic
that they were dealing with.
And then another series
would be somehow maybe a kind
of dialectic with the last
series or something very
different or a kind of perhaps
advancement on the ideas
of that or something.
And that's sort of how I
think about these things.
So for the longest time,
most of my life as a writer,
I had very much avoided
what you would call anything
autobiographical,
because I just thought
that was the least interesting
part of what I know or think
about.
So I somewhat arbitrarily
just embargoed all of that.
And then I had stopped
writing a little bit
and was doing movie
and TV kind of writing.
And then when I came
back to writing books,
I wrote a book called The
Sugar Frosted Nutsack."
And it had nothing of me in it.
My other books had had a kind
of very fictionalized version
of me, a very, very hyperbolic,
artificial version of the I,
the first person subject.
Then that book
had nothing of me.
It was about a set
of gods and goddesses
and a person named
Ike who believed--
like was the only person
on Earth who believed
in these gods and goddesses.
Which as I point out doesn't
mean they didn't exist,
it just meant they
chose to only be
in the head of this one person.
I think that's
perfectly plausible,
that gods and goddesses would
be-- could behave that way,
probably would behave that way.
So this book I decided,
let me try to do something
where I'm in every--
something auto--
like see what was that fear
or objection to talking
about, you know, musing.
I really think we all have a
kind of finite set of stories
that retrospectively determine
who we think we are and how we
present ourselves to other
people or to ourselves,
you know, maybe 20 stories.
And you find yourself
drinking is good for this.
You find yourself telling all
of them, in any given night.
After a number of hours,
you will dip into those
and exhaust them by 2:00,
3:00 in the morning,
and just start again.
So I said, let's think
about that and use those.
And we discovered, it's just as
interesting and uninteresting
as all the sort of
miscellaneous detritus
that you use in
your writing anyway.
It's the same.
You know, the sort
of membrane that
separates what you think of as
yourself and the outside world
is very porous and it's the
same stuff floating in and out.
So why I spent my whole life
avoiding it, I don't know now.
But now that's out
of my system, so--
AUDIENCE: So I think you
just answered my questions,
so I'll ask a different one.
When you wrote the previous one,
"The Sugar Frosted Nutsack,"
when you started that book,
how much of its structure
did you already have in mind?
Did you already
have it or did it
merge as you started writing?
MARK LEYNER: That
book, which I'm
assuming, out of my
saintly humility,
that you haven't
read, again, I have
very-- I don't know what you
call them-- architectonic
or geometric senses of books.
I really have an idea of
what the shape of a book is.
And it's much more
important to me
than the story or
the characters.
The shape of that book
was a kind of vortex.
And in fact at the
end, there's an image
at the end of the entire
book being embroidered around
and around and around
and around like a vortex
in a baseball cap, until you get
to that little nub on the top
and the book's sort
of ending there.
And that's how I always
imagined that book, some sort
of spinning and spinning
and then getting
in tighter and tighter and
tighter whirls of the vortex.
This book, "Gone with the Mind,"
I had, from the beginning,
an idea of doing a book
in the form of a reading,
in kind of three
acts, that there'd
be an introduction,
the reading, and a Q&A.
I found almost no advice you
get as a writer is useful.
And almost everything
I've ever been told
I've been most successful
by doing the opposite.
And I still try to do that.
If I show something to someone
and they say, oh it's very,
I don't know, it's
pornographic, I'd
just try to make it
more pornographic.
Or it's self-indulgent, I
make it more self-indulgent.
Just do the opposite.
Or it's too
sentimental, I make it
sickening like drenched
in molasses sentiment.
They're just showing me
the direction to go to.
So what was I going to say?
I lost my train of thought.
What were we talking
about, because there
was a kind of advice
someone gave me about this,
and now I can't
remember what it was
and what I did opposite to it.
Let me think for a second.
We're talking about this book.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] talking
without interrupting yourself,
and [INAUDIBLE]?
MARK LEYNER: Exactly.
Well, it'll come to me or not.
Anyway, I wish I could remember.
It was so brilliant.
Let me just think for
a second about this.
I don't know, lost it.
OK, I'm a reliable lecturer
here, half demented.
Can't even think of what the
beginning of his own sentence
was.
Anyway, thank you so
much for coming today
in the midst of such an
infernal day out there.
It was great, great to
meet you in this forum.
[APPLAUSE]